ensuite je regarde autour de nous dans
toutes les démocraties européennes y
compris chez nos voisins allemands où on
pensait impossible le retour de
l'extrême droite elle est là donc je
pense qu'il faut pas le voir simplement
avec nos yeux
franco-français quelque chose se
passe moi je pense qu'il faut pour
éviter le retour des extrêmes en
particulier de l'extrême droite
s'attaquer à ce qui fait voter pour eux
la première chose c'était le chômage de
masse c'était une SP une spécificité
française nous étions à coup sûr la plus
la grande économie qui n'avait pas
réussi à endiguer celui-ci on est en
train de le faire et on va continuer la
désindustrialisation on le voyait dans
nos territoires de l'Est comme du Nord
avait beaucoup nourri le Rassemblement
National Front national nager on est en
train d'y répondre on améliore
d'ailleurs les choses dans ces
territoires est-ce que c'est suffisant
non deuxème élément
l'immigration lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine c'est je pense
une des réponses au rassemblement
national c'est pourquoi j'assume
totalement la politique au niveau
européen et français qu'on a mené pas de
naïveté mais le faire dans le cadre de
notre République nos
principes ce que je défends mais il faut
s'attaquer à ça qui dans certaines
régions nourrit puis la troisième chose
qui je pense les nouriss c'est une forme
de sentiment de
dépossession beaucoup de nos
compatriotes se disent au fond le pays
marche plus on a tout essayé on les a
pas essayé et ma crainte et ce contre
quoi je me bats parce que je suis pas là
pour craindre vous me direz
c'est que tout le monde s'habitue à ça
et plus personne ne dit que le
rassemblement national comme toutes les
extrêmes droites en Europe c'est surtout
et avant tout le pays de
l'appauvrissement collectif c'est le
pays c'est pays c'est partie de
parti du mensonge et ça continue de
l'être c'est le parti qui a le programme
qui a complètement piqué à l'extrême
gauche c'est parti qui continue à vous
expliquer que la retraite à 60 ans est
possible sans vous expliquer comment la
financer parti qui vous explique qu'il
faut augmenter le SM sans vous expliquer
comment ça industrialisera pas le pays
c'est le parti qui continue de vous
expliquer des choses impossibles sur le
plan économique et social pour
affaiblir si on s'attaque pas pied à
pied à l'incohérence de leur programme
les gens se disent disent des trucs
facile l'opposition c'est beaucoup plus
facile que le gouvernement donc faut
aller au réel sur ce qu' propose et ça
c'est notre responsabilité collective ça
n'est pas que la mienne seule mais tant
qu'on continuera à avoir un discours
politique qui parfois est déréalisé
pas populaire de faire une réforme des
retraites ou de l'assurance chômage mais
si on continue à aller voir les gens et
qu'on trouve c'est formidable c'est une
réponse politique de leur dire on va
continuer de vous aider on va vous
remettre la retraite à 60 ans tout va
bien se passer 62 ans maintenant la deè
chose c'est le parti du
transformisme c'estd qu'il y a 6 ans et
demi pour sortir de l'Europe et de
l'euro et maintenant il est pour y
rester mais pour ne plus en respecter
les traités comme l'extrême gauche même
programme c'est le frexit caché c'est
l'appauvrissement de la France aussi
c'est des gens qui disent je suis plus
trop sûr de vouloir sortir de l'euro et
de l'Europe comme n guerre mais enfin
nous on respectera pas les traités avec
nous rassurez-vous mais c'est quoi vous
pensez que vous connaissez vous des
copropriétés où on continue à vous payer
l'eau et le gaz mais vous respectez rien
c'est ça leur programme faut le dire
faut se battre et dans un monde en
bascule comme je viens de l'évoquer face
à la Chine aux États-Unis d'Amérique
vous pensez qu'une une France toute
seule dans une Europe affaibli c'est une
bonne chose c'est ça le programme de
rassemblement national mais si tout le
monde s'habitue en disant ils sont
devenus sympathiques en fait ils disent
plus des choses qui nous heurtent parce
qu'on sait plus trop ce qu'ils disent
moi je vois le débat public sa plus trop
ce qu'ils disent enfin ils sont contre
ce que fait le gouvernement ça a l'air
sympa là à ce moment-là on rentre dans
un une forme de zone de danger qu'on
voit dans tous les pays européens parce
qu'on ne se bat plus PED à pied sur ce
qui est la R principes c'est pour ça que
moi
j'assume de continuer à présider au réel
avec un certain sens de
l'idéal